i just want to start us off i'd love to
know what drew you to to this movie as
your first official rom-com feature uh
scott i'll start with you
well the script was great i've read a
lot of rom-coms uh
not actually a lot but enough where you
know you read them and you know you're
like oh this could be good
if this if that
it's very i think seldom that you read
one and you la have multiple out loud
laughing moments
uh and i knew right away you're like oh
this is great this is gonna be good i
think for me my favorite
comedies in general are the ones that
are rooted in like the most
vulnerability because comedy
is
you have to put yourself in a more
vulnerable spot than drama in my opinion
for it to be funny and so when i read
this script and especially reading
jenny's character i was just like
that is so real and it's so
heartbreaking which then makes it
hilarious
and so i just i i just liked the combo
of having
heartbreak but it'd be funny you know it
just feels the most real that way
it's the best time to laugh when you're
like going through a tough time and
that's real life you know
for sure so
speaking of relationships they are
entirely chaotic but they also help us
grow
um
i think
i want you back really proves that and
i'm curious what was the greatest lesson
you guys took away from your past
relationships um that you took into this
and clark i'll start with you
none of the noise matters
like
and then i think this movie does a great
job of shining a light on
how social media plays into
like it makes it so much harder to let
go because you're like constantly
bombarded and it's also even if you're
not bombarded it's so easy to just find
it right there and it's just so easy to
compare but i would just say
yeah i think a lesson i learned is once
again just to like
not care too much
you know
yeah i don't know
i like that
i like that
um
yeah i would say
i would say that i think
i think maybe more like identifying uh
people that you're compatible with yeah
you know like
it's easy to
i think have passion in the in many
relationships when you when you first
meet someone everything is new and
exciting
um
but identifying
if that person is
consistent
consistency is is pretty big and having
i think a long-term relationship
for sure yeah i definitely agree
um and scott so
you've done a lot of action you've done
a lot of drama roles in the past
i want to know what was it like jumping
into this project and playing a more
comedic role especially across from
charlie i mean so there were some of
those scenes that i was like truly i was
like dying laughing it was hilarious
that's good i'm glad we made you laugh
because charlie
makes me laugh every day
and uh
to be honest i was really just lucky
because
i charlie when you're in a scene with
charlie he just
he makes you laugh and
getting to just kind of rebound off him
having a great partner like that it's
it makes you know really quite
quite easy and clark so jenny is quite a
different character from your character
rosie on letter kenny i was wondering
what kind of love advice do you think
jenny would give rosie that is
jenny would give jenny would give rosie
oh okay and your character in the other
show to nurse the thing is
they're both doing great i don't even
know that she'd i think she would just
go like
get a girl keep going like i don't even
think there's advice to give because
rosie is killing it keep going rosie
that's true toughest guy in letter kenny
so i think she's doing
just fine
and you guys have such great chemistry
on screen especially when it comes to
everybody as a group together and you
too how did you guys cultivate that was
there any um
like bonding moments or okay
zero alcohol
um
it didn't take any work i think we were
all lucky on this one where like
everyone was as humans and in character
just like so chill
and
like kind and funny and it was just like
one of those casts where there's just no
no rotten one everyone
smelled great
i like that
do i smell good
and is there any um is there any actor
that you didn't get to work a lot with
on screen that you wished you had more
scenes with and uh scott i'll start with
you with that one
gina is fun
and she's a total firecracker
and i think there could be some fun uh
there could have been some fun stuff to
explore there
i would say
character-wise like seeing the
characters interact it would probably be
manny's character just because
just so
weird
in such a great way like i don't even
know how ginny would react to manny like
i just think that'd be funny
i just want to know what has been your
experience like working on this i what
is this was this your first project
coming out of covid and what was it like
filming during you know during these
kind of weird times in our in our lives
i think it was my first one out of cobit
was it not yours i can't remember no i
did one during covid
um
it was good it was uh
you know i think
what we both have been talking about is
just
you know
it's hard to get to know people when you
everyone has a mask on every day that's
that's like a really tough yeah that's
the hardest part it's just like there's
a little less connection behind the
scenes which is what i
thrive on yeah um
but apart from that
i mean
productions and these film sets are
doing the best they can so we did the
best we could and it was still a great
time yeah it definitely looked like you
were having a good time which is why i
felt super natural
to see you guys i mean was it a real
riverboat that you guys were on it was
oh and i saw dolphins for my first time
ever on that riverboat oh yeah there was
dolphins in there wasn't there yes i
know that's probably not that cool to
you but it was very cool no it's cool
it's cool seeing them because it's kind
of the intercoastal waterway which yeah
essentially they come up through these
like rivers which is pretty cool yeah
i love it i love it well i really
enjoyed the movie and i really want to
thank you guys for taking the time to
speak with me i appreciate it
you